I actually sat down with will and had a
conversation he gave me his blessing
August Alsina is getting candid about
his past rumoured relationship with Jada
pinkett-smith people don't necessarily
know the truth but I've never done
anything wrong I love those people
literally like my family while chatting
with Angela Yee about his new album the
product to state of emergency not only
did the 27 year old singer claim he used
to be in a relationship with Jada but he
also alleged that Jada's husband of 22
years Will Smith gave him his blessing I
actually sat down with Will and had a
conversation due to the transformation
from their marriage to life partnership
that they've spoken on several times and
you know not involving romanticism
mm-hmm he gave me his blessing et has
reached out to Jada's rap for comment
but her team did tell page six that
August's claims are absolutely not true
romance rumors between August and Jada
have circulated for a while now and in
2019 fans speculated that the musician
song nunya was written about the 48 year
old actress
[Music]
but August denied those claims people
can have whatever ideas that they like
but what I'm not okay with is a my
character you know being in question I'm
not a troublemaker
you know I don't I don't like drama and
I also don't think that it's ever
important for people to know what I do
who I sleep with
who I date right but in this instance
it's very different because as I say
there's so many people that uh
side-eyeing me looking at me
questionable about it
August went on to explain that he's lost
money friendships and relationships over
the rumors because he says people don't
know the truth I totally gave myself to
that relationship for years of my life
you know and I truly and really really
deeply loved and have a ton of love for
her
I I devoted myself to it I gave myself
to it so much so to the point that I can
die right now and be okay with knowing
that I truly gave myself to somebody
right and he didn't stop there
August said he had never been in love in
that kind of a way and added that he
stayed silent for so long because he
didn't want to cause confusion being
intertwined in that way walking away
from me
butchered me like I'm shaking right now
because it it almost it almost killed me
not almost it it did it pushed me into
being another person in my newer stuff
broke me down meanwhile Will and Jada
have been vocal about the ups and downs
in their marriage during an episode of
red tabletalk in 2019 Jada said that she
and her husband haven't faced any
cheating issues in their relationship
but she did recall how she's been
cheated on in the past and has been the
one to step out on her partner I had a
really interesting experience when I was
younger I had two relationships before
well that were kind of serious to me
where I got cheated on which really
broke my heart
mm-hmm and then I cheated on somebody
that I really cared about and I have to
tell you me cheating on someone was more
devastating than me being cheated on in
January of last year the couple revealed
that they don't celebrate their wedding
anniversary it's more of a life
partnership yeah so it's not steeped in
their day in that day yeah so there's no
like we don't really celebrate that day
you know what I'm saying yeah anymore in
that sense because the context of our
union is totally different and in 2018
we'll opened up about his marriage
during an interview with titles rap
radar podcast we refer to ourselves as
life partners right where you get into
that space when you realize you are
literally with somebody for the rest of
your life
there's no deal-breakers there's nothing
she could do ever nothing that would
break our relationship she has my
support till death
[Music]